good morning again my name is Nick
Riddler I I'm gonna be talking about
this open source project one away there
we go called Pixley and this was my
first foray into open source and so all
the things that you know I learned over
the course the year I'm gonna be talking
about so first I want to talk about
Pixley with an eye so one of our
exclusive brands at stitch fix is Pixley
and they actually have a number of our
more popular tops and and other items
but I wanted to call out something
important we actually have a data
science team some colleagues on the
emerge product team developed or
designed a few tops and this is one of
them it's called the Curie and basically
these are what we call our Franken
styles we take components from different
kinds of top-selling items and we put
them all together and see how they do
and and there's actually a great blog
post here that I put in that details the
process and this was really neat but
Pixley with a why is actually a set of
helpers and widgets for a building flask
and react powered dashboards and so in
the last talk I believe they mentioned
this project called spire which is also
aimed to be somewhat shiny like in terms
of like our shiny this is supposed to be
a little bit more flexible it doesn't
rely so heavily on templating but rather
some patterns in the JavaScript and then
some Python wrappers so I'm gonna go
over this in more detail in a little bit
but first I just wanted to talk a little
bit about who I am they have some
context I'm a data scientist it's
districts and not a front-end engineer
right though so the first time I did any
sort of front-end work was that
statistics because I had to build a
dashboard and the first few dashboards
were in shiny but I'm not an active or
user and so it's much more difficult for
me to debug in R then say Python so I
want to do something flask
related I used to spend a lot of time on
Kegel my sort of soap box is on feature
engineering and how important that is
and so most of my career has been spent
around feature engineering and algorithm
development I worked in defense doing
signal processing for seven or eight
years and now I work on women's fashion
so so in this talk I'm going to tell you
a little bit about what led to Pixley
and go over what it actually is and give
you some more background but then also
lessons learned so it's a lot of like
what I thought was gonna happen and then
what actually happened because when
you're building a tool it's very easy to
just get caught up in you know this this
is what I'm trying to do and you have
all these examples but you have them
forget that there's gonna be a user
right and there's user that it's not
gonna understand any of the like design
ideas that you had or or the motivation
so I'm going to talk about that and then
talk a little bit about what's next so
real quick I wanted to give you an
introduction about how stitch fix works
so we have a stylist and a stylist picks
five items that they're gonna put into a
box alright and so what happens is we
have this recommendation engine that
takes all of our inventory and decides
for this piece of inventory this is the
probability that you're going to buy it
and so then a human stylist goes in and
says you know here's the curated list
that I get from the out algorithm this
is and maybe I have some requests notes
or some more information about the
client like what size they are and what
colors they like and you know what kinds
of items they wish to receive and so
they'll go in they'll pick five things
and so once those five things are chosen
we send them to to our clients and then
they get the option of keeping what they
like and returning the rest and so it's
really easy you get like a little bag
for returns you don't want something you
just put it in the bag and drop it in
and a blue mailbox so I work on the
merge algorithms team as districts and
so anything related to the inventory
like what should we should buy how much
we order
do we have the right mix of inventory
what should we throw away all those
kinds of questions are are handled by
the Murtagh rhythms team and so I work
on specifically inventory quality it's a
lot like feature engineering I'm trying
to come up with metrics that
characterize the health of our inventory
so that any given time we can know do we
have the right things and the way that
we provide our insights and feedback to
our business partners so I work
primarily with buyers and planners so
the buyers will actually go to market
and they'll find out you know here's the
dresses or the the tops that are going
to be popular for the next season and
the planners will do things like okay
well we have a warehouse how much would
be in the warehouse how many styles of
each department do we bring in and so on
and so forth and so we surface all of
that information through dashboards and
we have a lot of dashboards at stitch
fix something to use more than others
but I maintain a handful of them and
when I first started it was all shiny
app so we had this pattern of you are in
a sequel query the sequel query gets
dumped into a CSV file and then put on a
shiny server and then you have your
little app that reads it and renders it
but eventually as as the business grows
and as the types of information that
they want is a little bit different that
just we sort of outgrew shiny so now I'm
gonna give an overview of what Pixley at
it so really this was just an attempt
for me to avoid writing our I don't have
any problems with our I just found that
for shiny debugging the front end stuff
was a little bit more tricky if you're
working with like the stuff in Flast
then you know exactly what's being sent
through it's like JSON and you know you
can like look in the console for the
JavaScript and understand what's going
on so so so what I did was I've had some
tutorials and I made like the most basic
flask app that I could where I had a
button and I had a chart and the button
just hit some API root that said give me
data and that data just looked at some
panelist out of frame and filter
the data frame and returned some JSON so
whatever Jace in this case that's a pie
chart so maybe it was like you know some
category and some fraction and that sort
of thing but then you know this is a
neat toy problem but then as you start
adding feature requests like pretty
quickly like my code just became a mess
because it was just you know I even if I
tried to organize it there'd be you know
one file that was like full of different
routes and one file that was like full
of different ways to transform the
JavaScript and then then I had this
whole separate JavaScript project to
maintain and so it was not it didn't
really work for me and it wasn't
something that I felt like I could go if
someone if for whatever reason I was no
longer at stitch fix that whoever
inherited my code would be able to
actually read it and so so because I
spent some time working with shiny I
there is a lot of shiny that actually
really appreciate it and one of it one
of the things is sort of how they broke
down the the layout of the page and so
in most cases for the for the kinds of
things that I'm going to be doing I'm
just interested and I have some data
frame think it was like a table or you
know in a sequel database or something
and I have some sort of filters that I
want to select some some dimensions of
the data and just see that that data
frame cut under those dimensions and
then so in the in this UI dot our file
you get to specify oh these are the
different buttons and widgets and I want
and then you get to specify that kind of
charts and tables and things and then
there's a separate server dot R where
you can like specify how all these
things actually get the data so so going
back to my first example I have a simple
abstraction so I now have included the
like the JSON part and the the API route
as like a UI component and then the UI
component could be like a filter or it
could be a chart and the things that are
different or are how it gets and how it
sends data and all
and in all these cases I wanted the
ability to use like a just a panda's
data frame and so I wrote some really
like basic like rappers just to taking a
data frame filter with whatever you pass
it and then like spit out this JSON blob
and there's nothing that says it has to
be pandas you can actually like hook it
up to any other sort of data source so
in the end like I spent a week I took
the one dashboard that I made and I cut
it up in a bunch of different ways I
decided on the JavaScript pattern and I
wrote some Python wrappers but in
writing documentation or any tests so I
sort of threw this thing together all
that all so that I could have like like
one script where I said you know I'm
gonna have a UI I'm gonna add a button
I'm gonna add a chart and like that's
all I want and and all the other stuff
was taking care of in the other the
JavaScript or the Python so so then as
sort of like a dare wasn't really a dare
but like our platform director on our on
our algorithms team said oh just make it
open source right he's like there's
nothing that's just fixed proprietary
again they're just put it out there so
I'm sure and then at the time we were
also trying to write more blog posts and
so our like tech branding team said oh
write a blog post so I sort of threw
everything together thinking that there
would be zero interest it's like I don't
know that how many people are actually
building flask apps with react and
Python there's a lot seems like a lot
more people using shiny and so the first
lesson I learned is not to plan for zero
interest so I had no documentation no
tests that's gonna be no problem
nobody's gonna look at this anyways and
so what I thought was gonna happen would
be that like my github repo would be
like empty and then like nobody would
look at it what actually happened was it
like climbed to number two on Hacker
News
it got like 1500 stars and like suddenly
people were like really excited about it
which was which was overwhelming it was
awesome but
same time it was looks like okay maybe
it was a little premature to release it
and so like naturally had lots and lots
of issues and because one of the things
I don't know how many of you have tried
to build a project and like react lately
or any of these other things but there's
a lot of dependencies right so anytime
you introduce a dependency that's just
another point that someone could have a
problem installing right and so you
think about all the people out there
using different browsers different
versions of Python
you know if they happen to grab the the
wrong like version of some JavaScript
library like there's lots of ways that
this could sort of fall apart and so I
spent a lot of time over the last year
trying to think about like how can I
reduce those dependencies in fact I
think the last time I pushed a version
it was to wrap up a bunch of
functionality so that way there was some
like default JavaScript libraries that
would automatically pull and so if you
like ran this command-line function it
would just automatically install all
those things and you should be good to
go but these things are constantly
changing so it's sort of no guarantee so
the second lesson was then you know to
read some guides first before I just
start throwing things out there
so I think I found how to submit to pi
PI
and to pip install and all that sort of
thing but the the particular walkthrough
that I went through they didn't have
anything about like test servers and all
that stuff so I like made a whole bunch
of mistakes first and so as like a
reference I've included a bunch of links
for things I found were for useful we're
pretty useful so because some users were
Python too and some users were Python 3
kondeh environments are really great
because I could have a to environment in
a 3 environment test everything
separately and make sure everything
works and then and then publish or if
you use virtual and and by I happen to
use khandha and then there is some nice
like pi pi tutorials about you know if
you're gonna open source of a Python
package here are all the steps that you
need to take and I
wish I had found those the first time
that I searched but nevertheless
therefore for future reference
so the next part was making
straightforward examples and
documentation so I sort of thought well
you know the code is is sort of a
documentation there's a lot of different
things going on and you know it is one
way to the way that I happened to learn
new projects is to look at the source
code I realized not everybody does that
but it's a good way to sort of see how
things are going and so there's
documentation now but but even then it's
really hard to convey a lot of ideas
without and like an in concise
documentation so I think the problem
that I had was I I sort of thought when
I was putting all this together it was
like okay how can I show the most
functionality and like a few examples as
possible and so I showed these like at
first I think I had four different
examples one was using this metrics
graphics library which is pretty cool
it's by folks at Mozilla and then data
tables because a lot of the the kinds of
things that I was using in SHINee were
just these like simple bar charts or
line charts and tables and then maps are
always cool so I decided to show a map
and then there's some d3 integrations
where you can like have custom d3 with a
cross filter kind of thing and then in
data tables that library is like super
flexible so you can even put in SVG's in
a column and then have a function that
renders that and so in this example I
think I had like confidence intervals or
something like that which is kind of
cool but you know let's say that you're
a user and you're like how do I make a
table so say okay you see this you see
something called data tables so I go
look at this but but actually in that
example I'm just trying to show that
like how you can sort of hijack some of
the the data tables parameters
how you can just bind to a single UI
component how you don't have to have a
layout there so there's all these things
that like at the time I was like oh this
is great because I'm showing all these
different like features but like if
you're a user you actually are probably
just interested in like making a table
right and so I think it became too
confusing because like some one would
try one example and have no problems
another person will try a different one
and then just be completely lost and
give up and so I think it making good
examples was really hard and it takes a
lot of like reflection try to figure out
how you can make it as useful as
possible and so see into a pretty good
time and so the last lesson that I
wanted to to go over was just make sure
that it's something that you love
because you know it's gonna take a lot
of free time right and so like at first
I was thinking that you know open
sources collaboration right like I this
was my attempt to just put an idea out
there I was hoping that I would get some
design feedback because what I was doing
was pretty different there's a lot of
people that just it's very easy when you
work with a scripting language just
write lots and lots of scripts and so to
try to encapsulate and then modular eyes
like some of these components was
something that hadn't been done for and
so like in the JavaScript it's actually
using a factory pattern so the Python
actually just passes a string that says
what type it is so the Python says this
is a button and in the little bit of
template code that gets written out is
component with type is button and the
JavaScript says okay I know what a
button is and then it goes and builds a
JavaScript button so it's different from
some of these template approaches where
they just like create a template for all
the different kinds of things you could
possibly want and then and then and
create those things at run time whereas
this was trying to figure it out so I
was hoping then like P that people I
work with and then contribute widgets
because we have a number of like really
really beautiful dashboards like some of
the the people on my team I kept like
gone out of their way to make some of
these like awesome visualizations but
or at least I would hope was hoping for
something like new use cases but but
really it's just been primarily me
working on on Pixley I have like three
or four dashboards we there are there
are some people that will use it now and
then and I I do hear from from people
but I think the biggest barrier is that
if you know how to do something you'll
just do it right and so taking the time
to like learn a different framework is
always gonna be a hurdle and so then
like when it comes to my free time about
like what I'm gonna work on so I usually
think of it as like oh well I could like
maintain Pixley or I could have like you
know do something like hobby or
something or exercise and I found that
if I don't exercise that I think real
quick so the same thing goes with just
like not striking a good balance and so
I like especially working at a startup
even though stitch fix and our data
science team has become quite large like
there's there's still a sense of urgency
for a lot of the work that we do and so
trying to like strike a balance is hard
and so what often happens though is that
Pixley often loses right because you
know my job is more than just the
dashboards and so I'm not really
touching them very much and it's just
it's not something that that I
prioritize and the reason for that is I
wanted to share the bigger picture and
so this is an example of a stitch fix
web app one of the ones that I maintain
we use spark I mean sorry s3 is our
source of truth and then we use things
like spark and redshift and whatever to
to get out the data so I brought down a
to lose an s3 I run a spark ETL that
generates some features for me so like
you know maybe it's like binary
indicator variables maybe it's like
counts of the number of likes cues that
we have and then I because like working
with styles like once you go from having
a lot of data for a client's whatever to
like the style level that becomes much
much smaller and so then I can just pop
it into Python and run like SK learn or
something
and so then I can out
recommendations and so that all sits in
s3 and then I have a flask application
that just talks to s3 pulls the data
into a data frame and I have Pixley
sitting on that and then there's the the
react component on top of that and so
one of the reasons this works so well is
we have a super awesome Data Platform
team that has built some amazing tools
so all of the integration between like
s3 and SPARC and like redshift and
whatever is taken care of we use geni
for scheduling the spark jobs and then
we have a bunch of like custom like
readers and writers for 4s3
so but so this is a lot of stuff to
maintain and the dashboard is just the
last bit of it right so it's a pretty
small part of my job in fact there's
even another part of this which is like
all the modeling and data analysis that
goes into it that is also a huge time
sink and so I guess at the end of the
day I may be spending you know like 10%
of my time working on just the the front
front end layer and so the good thing
though is that I haven't really had to
write much JavaScript over the course of
last year because I've been using Pixlr
the only JavaScript that I've been
really writing is like when I want to
update something and so my JavaScript
skills are very very poor at the moment
the last time I tried to look at at
anything it was much more difficult than
than before but then you know one thing
that I'm realizing and is if you
integrate with JavaScript it takes
constant attention and part of that is I
mean react so I chose to use react but
react is evolving so quickly there's
been a lot of design changes and in the
last year they've gone from like version
0.13 to version 15.3 or I'm not even
sure if that's the current version but
they also used to have this thing called
pi react which so I don't know I know
how many of you are familiar with with
react but what react does it allows you
to write this JSX code which is sort of
a mix of JavaScript and HTML and then it
transpires that into
javascript well pi react was this Python
module that would take a string and so
it was perfect perfect for templates
because you could just put in all your
stuff transpile that to some JavaScript
and spit it out well they duplicated
that in favor of web web pack and Babel
and all these other like build tools and
so I had to remove that piece of it and
come up with a new sort of build process
and then other libraries have like Bing
API changes and so a number of them are
not to like version 1.0 yet and so
there's always going to be an interface
changes so let's see so maintaining an
open source project has been a bit of an
adventure
it's been both awesome and like
overwhelming because you know it it's
it's great when you hear that someone's
using something that you built but then
it's also you know very difficult to try
to like fit in time to help new people
or to come up with new features and all
these things and so it's like they're
always gonna be bugs they're always
gonna be like but it will never be like
enough documentation and testing
examples for everyone so it's it's been
a bit of a challenge and so the future
for this project I mean I'm gonna try to
keep up with react the best that I can I
think I'm I'm inversion point or 14 or
0.14 or something but for right now it
seems to work pretty well I think the
one barrier entry at the moment is this
is not really something for people who
have never set up a flask app I mean the
nice thing is flask is like really easy
to set up a a hello world and so once
you get familiar with just sort of how
things are moving around it's not so bad
but that is that is a barrier so if
someone is used to some other framework
then it's not so accessible and so I
realized that was kind of quick but
that's what I have so here's my contact
information I took all these like images
from like Final Fantasy and there's a
documentation and
github repository Thanks okay any
questions yes I think I would spend a
lot more time on the examples and trying
to make it easier cuz what I was going
for was something like shiny where you
could just have some script that defines
the UI and so like one of my or actually
all my projects they're really heavy on
the like the data manipulation like
there's a big part of it that's just
like pivoting and and aggregating all
these things and then I just have one
script that's the build UI part and so
that that works out really well and I
think communicating that has been the
hardest part because there's I think
people immediately see like oh I have to
do all these other things and it just it
can be overwhelming yes no oh sorry
sorry I repeat the question the before I
open source to any work on like making a
contributors guide or anything like that
no I I really just sort of put it out
there it was more of like just checking
public on github then than anything yes
the question is what I use the same
tools going back in time knowing that
reactors is so has been so volatile I
really like react in the sense that the
way it's organized makes a lot of sense
to me and it's actually made this whole
thing really easy because then I can
just sort of like the code is very
modular so I can just have some set of
like filters like buttons or dropdowns
or or whatever and the the layout is is
very similar so it's yeah I think from a
design standpoint there's a there's a
lot to like about it and so I think that
I probably would stick with it thank you